you guys asked for they deliver we found
out the episode titles and descriptions
for the first three episodes so let's do
a breakdown there's a new round of that
HBO now giveaway I'll explain that at
the end of the video but episode 1 is
titled Dragonstone it says jon organizes
the defense of the north Circe tries to
even the odds in Daenerys comes home so
we've seen a lot of footage in the
trailers that looks like it's from the
first couple of episodes John talking to
the lords in the Great Hall of
Winterfell we need to band together
trying to explain to them the threat of
the White Walkers the only ones who
would immediately take John at his word
are the wildlings who literally
experienced hardhome and everything
that's happened since then in Game of
Thrones it's largely you don't believe
something till you see it like you have
Tyrians character you have sir Jorah
that didn't believe in magic until they
met Daenerys and met her dragons so you
see it in the first couple of seasons
with Jorah then finally as they're
traveling together he gives the speech
to Tyrion just like he experienced it
then during season five Tyrion finally
meets the Dragons and it blows his mind
so that just needs to happen for some of
these Lords of the north John sounds
like he's going to have some problems
it's not going to be a really easy
slam-dunk and I just did that video
about how sophie Turner and Aiden Gillen
talked about how sanso and Littlefinger
don't want to have anything to do with
John ruling in the north so however that
manifests whatever pushback they give
him they'll be fighting each other so
it's not like John is going to roll up
in episode one everyone's going to
believe everything he says take him at
face value and then they'll all be
totally cool with forming an alliance
with Cersei and the new Daenerys who's
landed at Dragonstone so we'll see if a
raven makes it to Winterfell as Daenerys
makes it to Dragonstone it just depends
on how fast they disseminate information
because as of right now nobody in the
north has referenced anything that's
going on with Daenerys storyline they've
mostly been focused on the Bolton's in
the last season the only time you really
hear Daenerys referenced in the Seven
Kingdoms is obviously the south and
Dorne as well as King's Landing going
back to Robert in season one the people
the north don't seem to be very
concerned with the Targaryen restoration
but when they say Cersei tries to even
the odds
that's probably Highgarden because in
the trailer we see Jaime walking past
what looks like a
Tyrel soldier on battlements so it looks
like that's one of the big victories
that they have so obviously
Daenerys is forces are charging in to
Casterly Rock they get their asses
handed to them but I think they want to
show that the Lannisters do have really
badass forces and Jamie isn't completely
incompetent so he will have some major
victories during these battles and it
could be through samwell's father they
could offer them Highgarden in exchange
for their help because randyll Tarly is
one of the best battle commanders in the
Seven Kingdoms so if you wanted to take
Highgarden
you would just get somebody who is a
real badass who is right next door to
help you out as for that last little bit
about Daenerys coming home that's
self-explanatory that is all these
scenes of her landing on Dragonstone
touching the sand on the beach walking
into our throne room for the first time
like you can see this brassiere that's
been knocked over you can tell that it's
been left in a mess people left it
haven't been backs in so a lot of the
fun of these moments will just be seeing
her reacquaint herself with her family's
history because she hasn't been back
here since she was born and she was born
during a great storm while they were
fleeing Dragonstone which is kind of
funny because episode 2 is literally
called Stormborn
Daenerys receives an unexpected visitor
John faces a revolt and Tyrion plans the
conquest of Westeros
so some of this footage is actually
shown up in the trailers the last little
bit about Tyrion planning the conquest
of Westeros you see his hand knocking
over the lion on the great map table the
unexpected visitor that Daenerys
receives might be Melisandre because I
don't think that Jon Snow shows up yet
because it says that he faces a revolt
so it sounds like he's still dealing
with stuff at Winterfell with Sansa and
Littlefinger plot isn't that when you
hear Littlefinger and Sansa talk about
how they're going to be fighting Jon for
control of the north and then they
mentioned revolt in the description of
an episode it sounds like they have
something to do with that in episode 3
is called the Queen's Justice Daenerys
holds court Cersei returns a gift and
Jamie learns from his mistakes so the
first big thing Daenerys holding court
this sounds like it might be the episode
where Jon Snow and Davos show up on the
beach at Dragonstone you can see the
rocks behind them here so that could be
episode 3 it could be a
for later in the season but there are
only seven episodes so it sounds like
they're not going to put that off for
too long if the idea of her holding
court is just her being Queen in
Dragonstone sitting on the throne so you
get a lot of those really big badass
moments with Daenerys on dragon back but
she's there to become the queen so
they're really only been a couple times
in the past couple seasons where she's
actually held court and listened to
other people the way a traditional king
or queen would you actually had to sit
there and listen to people petitioning
you for help we even saw bran doing it
back when he was still Lord of
Winterfell for that brief period before
he took off so I should actually mention
that two people have been talking about
this and we'll see how big of a deal it
becomes but technically brand has the
greatest claim to Winterfell so when he
returns if he wanted to he could take
Winterfell from Jon and Sansa because
he's the oldest living legitimate male
heir of Ned Stark of pure blood and
everybody knows that Jon Snow's a
bastard so as much as they love him his
claim isn't quite as strong as brands
and because Sansa female her claim also
isn't as strong as brands but when it
says that Cersei returns a gift that
could have something to do with the sand
snake some of the big battles they're
having with the Targaryen restoration it
sounds like most of her fight in the
early episodes is going to be with the
Queen of thorns and the other people in
the south although there are big battle
scenes that we see in the trailer with
Daenerys forces in the unsullied with
the Dragons scorching the earth but when
you talk about returning gifts who would
be giving her gifts other than euron
greyjoy
there was an event during Aegon's
conquest where he sent an envoy to treat
with Harun hor they chopped the envoys
hands off and sent the hands back to
Aegon that was when he made the decision
to conquer the Seven Kingdoms so he's
like okay that's it ultimatum you either
bend the knee or I will raise you to the
ground
I think of Cersei as being more like
maegor the cruel but they could just
have her returning gifts in a sinister
way or it could just be a legitimate
gift like an actual gift that you're on
gave her but when it says that Jamie
learns from his mistakes that could be
battle mistakes but it also could be
social political mistakes that he's
making with Cersei so that they're
slowly driving a wedge between those
characters it might take the entire
season to actually bear fruit but
typically when they tease big character
arcs they're metaphors for everything
that's going on like for the
war stuff that's happening for the more
personal character relationships they're
happening so let me know in the comments
what do you think about these episode
titles there's seven total so they'll
probably wait a little while to reveal
the rest of the four they typically roll
out episode titles in waves so we're not
going to find out the title of the
finale - like right before the finale
but we can all guess when we get a
little bit closer but like they did with
season six the last episode was called
winds of winter expect very big book
references with the final couple of
episodes so there will be more new Game
of Thrones this weekend I wasn't
expecting this information this quickly
which is great believe all your video
requests for topics in the comments
below
congratulations to sergeant sue you're
the latest giveaway winner please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details you can click here to learn more
about what Sansa and Littlefinger are
going to be doing during the season and
you can click here to learn about Game
of Thrones at comic-con this year thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight